i don't think i am really
knowledgeable enough to say
how accurate that is
it seems about right when i went to the
washington class championships
i played
i played a
1900 there was 2200 on leaches i played
a 1700 that was 2100 on chess.com but
once again i think it's bless already
stated or someone already stated
players in washington are generally
underrated because of the dual rating
system
yali chess is i think definitely a
little bit inflated okay he plays h4
i'm pretty sure the move here is g4 and
after knight e5 you play d6
and i think this is
this is some theory
yeah i would estimate that my actual
uscf playing strength is
um probably between 1900 and 2100
in classical truss
okay
i think the move here is knight f6
i think chess.com actually gets
more new users
because people have never played chess
before they just search chess right i
think chess.com or they even just go to
chess.com
like without even knowing that it's a
site you just like
they think to themselves i could
probably play chess at chess.com
and then they just go to chess.com
okay
let's just keep developing
no problem i'm assuming black is gonna
white's gonna castle here
they did not castle
didn't castle okay
round two
was like in a castle oh i guess now they
could castle
because before i was threatening queen
d4
it'd pick up the bishop but
now they've defended their bishop so
okay
they still didn't castle
dang it
well
i think now is a perfect time to play
knight d4
perfect time to play
my favorite move
ever
oh no my pawn oh dude
oh my goodness i
totally forgot about this pawn bro
jeez
two attackers and like
dang bro
he didn't take it
why didn't he take it
why didn't he take my pawn
well
that is really lucky that he didn't take
our pawn
he's really generous of him
very generous
well i guess that uh
since he didn't take our pawn we may as
well save it
right
might as well
might as well
you beat forrester on chess.com
that's pretty cool
i think most people have both accounts
yeah i think there are advantages to
both
i also have an account on both websites
have beaten santa claus
dang
1900 boots only chess
right now i'm
2200 blitz only chess
i've peaked at 2300 blitz though
and on chess.com i am i think i'm 2100
blitz
so once you get to like the higher
ratings i think it starts to sort of
even out
okay
well
i think that's a blunder
forgotten
other lives
all i care for is you and i
let's start by taking
let's take
and get that bishop out of here it's an
annoying bishop very annoying
and now
we say
well i would really like to take this
but he can just take with the queen
and that looks good for him
i'd really love to oh no my queen
but
unfortunately
cannot
now it's kind of tricky
if you play that move
well
now i've got this move
good game
did you guys see that
not a very
not a very good
move
blunder we were winning the whole game
nice
played perfect theory for
eight moves
and then bishop c4 was a blunder by our
opponent
and we punished him pretty well here
pretty well
made some small inaccuracies i
considered this move i considered
playing this move saying oh no my queen
okay uh next game is happening right now
though oh almost forfeited loso 77 good
luck to you